[Music]
on this thursday night the pressure to
remove president trump from office
the chorus of voices including some
republicans calling for trump
to go the president is unfit
and the president is unwell and the
blame he's taking for instigating the
mobs
who stormed the u.s capitol i wish we
could say we couldn't see it coming that
isn't true
accusations of a double standard the
weak police response to this mob
compared to the heavy hand against the
black lives matter protests
class concerns new evidence about
asymptomatic people spreading the
coronavirus
in schools and another vacation
revelation
a public health agency manager's free
holiday
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the world is watching the u.s tonight
after an attempted coup instigated by
president trump
it failed but it came frighteningly
close to disrupting the peaceful
transition of power
trump has 13 days left in office and
efforts are now
underway to keep him from doing any more
damage
president has committed an unspeakable
assault
on our nation and our people this is
urgent this is emergency of the highest
magnitude
there are calls for trump to be removed
from office before his term
ends the aftermath inside the u.s
capitol the shattered glass and the
furniture has now been cleaned up but
the scars from what happened there run
deep
four people died one of them a woman was
shot in the capitol building
by the police the goal of the violent
group was insurrection to stop
president-elect joe biden's election win
from being certified
that failed late yesterday evening
senators went back to work
the chair declares the joint session
dissolved
just before 4 a.m this morning biden's
victory was officially
confirmed today biden called what
happened
one of the darkest days in u.s history
they weren't protesters don't dare
call them protesters they were a riotous
mob insurrectionist domestic
terrorist the fbi and the police are
asking for help identifying those who
took
part police are facing tough questions
about why they were so unprepared and so
outnumbered
and late tonight president trump posted
a video on twitter in which he appeared
to finally concede like all americans i
am outraged by the violence
lawlessness and mayhem and to those who
broke the law
you will pay my focus now turns to
ensuring a smooth orderly and seamless
transition of power
but trump ended that statement by
telling his supporters
i want you to know our incredible
journey is just beginning
jackson proskow begins our coverage
tonight
the aftermath of a violent insurgency
inside the u.s capitol
an attempt to shatter democracy that
delivered a swift end to president
donald trump's hopes of clinging to
power
a very dangerous person who should not
continue
in office this is urgent this is
emergency of the highest
magnitude a chorus of lawmakers
democrats and republicans
calling for trump's immediate removal
from office it's time to invoke the 25th
amendment
and to end this nightmare either through
the 25th amendment to strip the
president of his power
or through impeachment which democrats
say they will consider if vice president
mike pence doesn't act to remove trump
while it's only 13 days left
any day can be a horror show for america
the violent mob was incited by trump's
incessant lies about a stolen election
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen you don't
concede when there's
theft involved
[Applause]
but an attack on the capitol was a
bridge too far for republicans who've
stood by him until now
but i can't stay here not after
yesterday you can't look at that
yesterday and think i want to be a part
of that
in any way shape or form transportation
secretary elaine chao became the first
cabinet member to resign
joining nearly a dozen other
administration officials there are
tenuous days ahead
i'm not worried about the next election
i'm worried about getting through the
next 14 days trump has positioned
himself as a comeback candidate in 2024
a figure whose supporters could loom
over president-elect joe biden
you're all going to have a lot of
questions it's biden who's set to
inherit the powder keg created by his
successor
but first america must get through these
perilous weeks ahead
the past four years we've had a
president who's made his contempt for
our democracy
our constitution the rule of law
clear in everything he has done
tonight crews are in the process of
installing a new reinforced
non-scalable security fence outside the
capitol complex
inside the national guard is patrolling
the grounds these are security measures
that will be in place for at least the
next 30 days that's through the end of
the trump administration
the inauguration and the first few weeks
of the biden administration
donna jackson it looks like trump's
twitter account is now active again but
his facebook account is frozen at least
until the end of his presidency he can't
use it to incite more violence
but he is still president he still has
the nuclear codes how likely is it he'll
be removed from office before he can do
any more damage you know we're in this
tense standoff right now
waiting to find out exactly how this is
going to play out a short time ago the
white house press secretary
delivered a statement condemning
violence but the point is she's making
that statement
president trump is not and he's the only
one who can call off his supporters at
this point
the dam may be breaking in terms of
support both from elected officials and
unelected officials
but at this point it's a matter of
seeing who blinks first in these coming
days
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks there's lots of talk about using
the 25th amendment of the u.s
constitution to remove trump from office
before his term expires
here's what it is the 25th amendment can
be invoked if for
any reason a president is unable to
carry out their duties
the vice president then assumes the
powers and duties temporarily
section 3 allows the transfer of power
voluntarily
george w bush did that twice for brief
periods while he had routine
colonoscopies
section 4 though has never been invoked
it empowers the vp and a majority of the
cabinet to
declare a president unable to discharge
the powers and duties of his office
if the president objects he will
eventually retake his powers unless the
vice president and cabinet
are supported by two-thirds majorities
in both the house and the senate within
21 days
even then the president can keep trying
to return
forcing new votes
senior republicans enabled and supported
trump and now some are abandoning ship
in his final days in office but where
does this leave the party
that's what eric sorenson is looking at
few stood to lose more from donald
trump's shrinking political world than
georgia senator kelly lefler
on january 6th i will object to the
electoral
college vote january 6 the senator
learned she'd lost her seat
the same day a mob egged on by trump
ransacked the capital
and finally lefler gave up helping trump
overturn the election
and i cannot now in good conscience
object to the certification
of these electors republicans see a
reckoning coming
we've had a hell of a journey i hate it
then this way
oh my god i hate it among those
abandoning trump's unwinnable bid to
stay in office
his golf buddy senator lindsey graham
when it's over it is over it is over
even trump's loyal vice president
presided over the final vote sealing
biden's
victory and trump's fate the chair
declares the joint
session dissolved
[Applause]
now will trumpism outlast trump himself
i'm inclined to think that the
trump movement will be relatively
short-lived the key is the personality
once that is removed it is very likely
to fragment some republicans are ready
to move on from what happened
yesterday because our kids need to know
that
this isn't what america is but others
say this is what america is
just the tip of trump's millions of
voters and demonizing democrats is a
model
ambitious republicans are ready to carry
on they intend to change this country
not for a year not for 10 years but for
generations
senators like ted cruz and josh hawley
hope to inherit
trump's voters millions of americans
concerned about our election integrity
but over holly's shoulder another
republican tested a different message
the best way we can show respect for the
voters who are upset
is by telling them the truth the big
truth
trump lost the election he has split his
own party fighting that truth
but it's created an opening for
republicans to choose
between trumpism and something new eric
sorenson global news
the federal prosecutor for the district
of columbia says all options are on the
table for charges against the mob
including sedition
police say more than 90 people have been
arrested but what has not been answered
is why the mob got
inside so easily the chief of the
capitol police force said tonight he's
resigning
many people including joe biden have
said if this had been a black lives
matter protest instead
of mostly white trump supporters the
police response would have been
dramatically different
mike armstrong reports
washington's mayor is calling what
happened wednesday in her city a
catastrophic security failure muriel
bowser is asking congress to hold a
commission
into what went wrong both to hold people
accountable
and to ensure that it never happens
again
the criticism of police action ranges
from questioning their effectiveness
to questioning their effort one
tennessee congressman says at times
officers appeared complicit and that
he's never seen a crowd
less afraid of police even during the
siege there was criticism from people
in the crowd there's not enough cops
here to handle us
and that's troubling now it's clear
police were outnumbered
and slow to call in reinforcements the
former head of capitol police says
officers needed help and it came too
late the cavalry should have been coming
to get those people to hell off the
steps and the platforms
but that would have been very very ugly
and difficult to do if you didn't have
superior force
there was also an intelligence failure
police underestimated the scope of the
threat
posed by the rally the chief saying
thursday they knew people were coming
but didn't expect what came next there
was no
intelligence that suggested there would
be a breach of the u.s capitol
we're going to walk down to the capitol
now that police would be surprised
has shocked many this was a rally with
tensions running high just a short walk
from where the president's
fate was being decided there's also been
anger brewing on social media
including calls to storm the capitol
this rally has been planned for weeks
they knew this was going to happen and
there should have been thousands of
national guards
now many are pointing to last summer and
how different the preparation and
reaction was
for black lives matter protests no one
can tell me
that it had been a group of black lives
matter protesting yesterday
there wouldn't have been they would have
been treated very very differently we
all
we all know that's true and it is
unacceptable
the president-elect says his own
granddaughter sent him this photograph
it's from last june on the steps of the
lincoln memorial national guard prepared
for a black lives matter protest
you can't help but acknowledge that
there is a double standard at least a
perceived double standard and it's
pretty blatant with criticism swirling
around him the capitol police chief
is now resigning announcing late
wednesday he's stepping down
effective january 16th mike armstrong
global news
the attempted coup in washington is
deeply unsettling for america's
neighbors and allies the trump effect is
not
limited to the u.s he has sympathizers
here in canada too
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson has been talking to security
and intelligence insiders about that
mercedes
donna a senior government source
described the events that unfolded
yesterday
as shocking but not surprising given the
last four years
and the plan here in ottawa will be the
same as for the rest of the roller
coaster that has been the trump
presidency
taking a calm tone focused on canadian
national interests
but also ready for anything because with
donald trump there can always
be surprises the hope here is to simply
ride out the end days of the
administration relying on contacts with
administration officials that canada has
a strong relationship with
although i'm told that there are no
major outstanding issues
that should need the president's
attention when it comes to canada
canadian officials believe that donald
trump is clearly not focused on
anything but himself right now there
will be a lasting effect though they
believe
on u.s democracy and as the u.s
political mood
seeps up here into canada which means
canadian intelligence officials will be
watching closely
according to the former head of csis
to the extent there are links back and
forth across the border
in terms of right-wing organizations and
people moving back and forth
i'm sure our organizations will be
working with the americans in
into the future to ensure that there are
no problems
canadian national security agencies are
watching message boards and
communications
according to a senior national security
source
but the fear is less that a mob would
overrun parliament here
than the damage that is being done
through conspiracy theories
attempts to undermine people's faith in
democratic institutions and elections
and even basic facts and that there will
be potentially a long-lasting effect in
canadian politics
well after donald trump leaves office
donna
okay mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks silently spreading the
coronavirus coming up new insight into
how often people with no
symptoms are infecting others
students in southern ontario will have
to wait until january 25th before
returning to in-person learning
ontario's premier says one in five
children under the age of 13 who have
been tested
are carrying covid19 and as a result
schools will stay closed for now
but in alberta a decision has been made
to send all students back to class on
monday
as heather urix west explains the covet
19 situation across the country is far
different now than at the start of the
school year
like so many parents alicia higa is just
trying to take things
day by day between broken
links that don't work and them getting
frustrated me getting frustrated
it's i'm at a point where it's just
you do what you can and just move on two
of her three kids are learning virtually
right now
sitting at a computer for hours on
monday they'll head back to class
the decision to resume in class learning
on january 11th is based on
carefully considering the importance of
attending school in person
as well as the latest evidence of cases
dropping
in all school-related age groups in
december
the bremer says he's confident kids can
return to classes
safely but this expert isn't so sure
i do think that there's plenty of reason
to be concerned and i'm certainly
concerned about
the idea of having children return to
the classroom
as early as next week dr jim kilner says
it's still
not clear that infection levels in
alberta are actually on the decline
and at current levels of community
spread he says there is growing evidence
that open schools
can lead to more transmission among
asymptomatic kids
the thing that's evolved as well is an
understanding that schools can be
contributing
to the rise of disease in the community
i don't think anybody can comfortably
save that schools
don't contribute to transmission of
infection
it's why in southern ontario where daily
case numbers are still on the rise
schools will remain closed to in-person
learning for at least
another two weeks i know this is a tough
one
it's tough for everybody and we know
those parents have worked hard at this
and having the virtual learning is not
easy trying to manage
their two different schedules my own
schedule
and my four-year-old i can't imagine if
there are people working from home right
now
back in alberta higa says she's not
worried about covet 19.
her kids have never had a case in their
classes but the reality
is it's january and the pandemic is now
in a very different place
than it was in the fall heather urex
west global news calgary
there's new data from the u.s showing
how asymptomatic and pre-symptomatic
people
are spreading the coronavirus modeling
done by the u.s centers for disease
control and prevention shows
asymptomatic people transmit more than
half of all coven 19 cases
35 percent are people who infect others
before they show symptoms
24 percent are from people who never
develop symptoms
researchers say the findings reinforce
the importance of following
all public health guidelines whether you
feel sick
or not bad influencers still ahead a
canadian public health official takes an
all expense paid trip
to jamaica
a senior manager at the public health
agency of canada has apologized for
taking an all expense paid trip to
jamaica
ignoring all the warnings about avoiding
non-essential travel dominique baker
flew with a friend to jamaica in
mid-november and stayed
in an upscale resort the trip was paid
for by air canada vacations which
she promotes as a social media
influencer
the timing just wasn't right and i
shouldn't have gone
and i urge anyone thinking of getting
away this winter
to wait until this pandemic is over
good advice she failed to take baker is
the manager of public health canada's
office of border and travel health
which is focused on keeping communicable
diseases out
of canada next how fragile is democracy
even in a rich and powerful country
what happened yesterday in washington
d.c will be the legacy of donald trump's
presidency
mob's running riot through the u.s
capitol summoned there by trump himself
stoking their anger telling them the
vice president had the power to overturn
the election result
the last desperate reckless act by a man
who came close to melting the
foundations
of the american republic
this is how democracy can crumble driven
by a leader who refused to accept he
lost an election
trump supporters did this in his name
intoxicated by four years of his
incendiary rhetoric
believing his baseless claims the
election was stolen
people motivated to action by lies
they stormed the u.s capitol carrying
confederate flags
vandalizing intent on stopping the
peaceful transfer of power
because their leader told them to we
will never give up we will never concede
it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's theft
involved
our country has had enough we will not
take it anymore let's have trial by
combat
that rallying cry answered by a mob
even erecting a makeshift gallows a
noose just steps from the u.s capitol
this was an attempted coup and i wish we
could say we couldn't see it coming
but that isn't true we could
see it coming the past four years we've
had a president
who's made his contempt for our
democracy
our constitution the rule of law
clear in everything he has done
a vivid chilling reminder democracy is
fragile
and america is not exceptional the
question remains whether the instigator
of this
donald trump will ever be held
accountable
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
in the heart of washington the u.s
capitol is being fortified the high
fencing to remain in place
for at least 30 days thanks for watching
hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye